[Musique]
les commissions sur vos organes
essentiels au bon fonctionnement des
deux champs parlementaires elle prépare
le débat législatif qui aura lieu en
séance publique contrôle le gouvernement
et en forme les sénateurs au Sénat il en
existe 7 et chacune d'elles les
compétences dans un domaine bien
particulier il y a la commission des
affaires économiques la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense la
commission des affaires sociales la
Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
la commission de la culture de
l'éducation et de la communication la
commission des finances et la commission
des lois
elles sont composées d'environ 50
sénateurs répartis suivant la nécessité
proportionnelle c'est-à-dire en fonction
du groupe politique auquel ils
appartiennent un sénateur ne peut être
membre que d'une seule de ses
commissions mais il peut faire partie de
la commission des affaires européennes
qui vient s'ajouter aux sept commissions
permanentes du Sénat mais alors
concrètement comment les commissions
participent-elles à l'élaboration d'une
loi imaginons que le gouvernement dépose
un projet de loi sur la santé en
arrivant au Sénat il est renvoya la
commission des affaires sociales qui lui
attribue un rapporteur celui-ci va en
premier lieu étudier le texte et
recueillir des informations auprès
d'experts concernés par le sujet puis il
va présenter son travail aux autres
membres de la commission et leur
suggérer des modifications
ce sont les fameuses amendements durant
cette réunion de commission d'autres
sénateurs peuvent également en proposer
ils sont ensuite adoptés ou non par un
vote puis le texte est soumis au vote
des 348 amateurs pendant la séance
publique une fois la loi votée il faut
s'assurer qu'elle est appliquée et ça
aussi ce sont les commissions qui s'en
charge chaque année elle publie un bilan
de l'ensemble des décrets arrêtés et
ordonnance prie pour appliquer une loi
mais leur mission de contrôle ne
s'arrête pas là en réalité les
commissions contrôlent l'ensemble des
actions du gouvernement
ce contrôle se fait par le biais
d'audition de déplacement et de rapport
la commission des lois peut par exemple
auditionner le ministre de l'Intérieur
sur l'organisation des élections ou
celle des affaires économiques peut
interroger le ministre de l'Agriculture
sur l'adaptation au changement
climatique cette permanence dans le
contrôle permet au Sénat d'assurer le
bon fonctionnement de la démocratie et
de jouer son rôle indispensable de
contre-pouvoir
[Musique]